шляхом будинку забираєте до монітора на
допомогу для сепаратистів то мирних
мишкати всім сходу україни ми люди ми
люди з прибалтики
розумі і міццю видує нас правді або
заражає на інформаційні ну ми і
Петро і mammut їхніх людей Якіо панелі силу
дружнього днів жити тобі ситуації
життєві ситуації
активі збору кошти на те гуманітарну так
по моя майя не прирікай успіх віджив
латвії мішка welicoruss є команди на
у кожного третього тут руська куріння та
by 6 вчора намаяться допам ух ти я думаю
що це важливо і обожнюю що це важливо для
шкіряний або ден і
отже ми живемо у тут spooky ну і мер ну а
там блюдах і ну чого вмирає
вже дві машини з допомогою активісти
народної гуманітарної волонтерської
руку балті подання правило на донбас esp
одягаюся в інші треба рис може заруби ти
там навчаються на просто
у нашій Україні країні в організацію
центрі латвійське стілець і тип від rapala
пе-2 в нкр і такий я [ __ ] до він вона
лиж з бра я по жертви аїр і крутий
об'єктив для петренко сепаратистів
станислав book in a dance volunteering
обирають допомогу
гвинта та його друзів інтенсивно 3 ну це я
зрозумів пояснювати для самооборони та будемо
супроводжувати поманить акули буду мусу
право живуть його унітарний vantage у мені
шви тк тікати ця сутичка в останній
момент з правильного боку пляшку можна
реально were to wait і жити а там ще до
хитрі ваяти обстріли українську армію
мирного населення Володимир Ліндерман
на приході що російські добровольці з
латвії йдуть висновок і до Донецька і Луганська.
when сомбра крутого бойовики у яких з
людожер їх я знаю ти мої давно товариші
з російського руху тут у латвії якумо
вже 15 rocky
а не для них тебе під рушницю було телицею
природну я схоплю їх ні в чиїх ніг ви
не самі забралась і шлях самі вибрали
свій шлях
латвійський спецслужби з осягають за так
і майкле enderman отже бойовики воюють на
Донбас можеш that in забезпеченими
і для латвії та радикали в чаті на
донбасі якар залишайтеся з бровою я
кафедри вати людей то я квести
партизанську війну разом дуло твого не
ушкоджується в радикалі поклику нам це
мужик
застосування своєї в міні проти нашої
національні спектри теж нікому в
підвалі руку болті на увазі вся випалення bull
та конфісковано телефон це комп'ютери
члени організації єс прийняв особи та від
провокацію щось порвана хоче фінансово 53
moto вину за так дзвінок але у росії ми
домовитися там і думалося про тещу
тпр людям з нашої допоможеш можете
відправляти та пожертвувати фонду новоросії
новоросія латвія вже 24 р. cayenne
закладену до іржаву
all russian з України так і призначив і
сухому місці у латвійському суспільстві та
цін на думку експерти у піджі у лени
store не налаштуєш туди заради омських
чисел болти туди тільки з ю у нас двох
організацій як їх як волантис кірюх
балті означаючи заради омський союз
он і запарюють нашу незалежність ми
болти моєму національний інтернет домени
для естонії та литви це латвії тани
дідька до європейського союзу по єдиній
зістрибнув стадій аеробусів
російською ан шин е до петр i маса
протестую донбасі посіяло страх з
радара що жителі латвії геть і бояться
що боротьба за так зла на нову росію з
полотні
і в них не державі